sans surprise ce matin ericoquerel le
président et les filles de la commission
des finances valide l'examen de la
proposition de loi du groupe liote il y
a eu pas mal de pressions qui ont été
faites ces derniers jours sur ma
décision y compris là je m'étonne un peu
quand même beaucoup venant de l'exécutif
et que je trouve un peu paradoxal que
l'exécutif se mêle à ce point d'une
décision qui va être purement
parlementaire c'est la première fois
sous la Cinquième République qu'un
président de la commission des finances
a une posture partisane et pas une
posture qui devrait être la sienne le
respect des institutions monsieur
Coquerel aimerait que l'articarante
n'existe pas très bien c'est son droit
mais aujourd'hui cet article il existe
il doit l'appliquer et s'il remplit
pleinement sa mission institutionnelle
il devrait déclarer la proposition de
loi ou à tout le mois l'article 1 il
recevable parce que quelqu'un vous dit
qu'un objet rouge est devenu bleu que
l'objet est devenu bleu pour autant donc
on tient à la clarté des couleurs et il
revient au Parlement dans sa
souveraineté de déterminer si le bleu
est bien bleu ou si le bleu est devenu
rouge donc si Eric Coquerel ne prend pas
ses responsabilités est-ce que vous en
présence de l'Assemblée vous prendrez
les vôtres bien sûr donc il n'y aura pas
de vote nous verrons mais en tout cas je
prendrai mes responsabilités c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale et c'est ce
qu'attend de moi mes collègues et
surtout les Français dans une démocratie
chahutée par votre gouvernement ou la
séparation des pouvoirs est un principe
fondamental de notre République jusqu'où
êtes-vous prêt à aller dans le
dévoiement de nos institutions pour ne
pas perdre la face on ne peut pas créer
une charge sans la compenser alors on
l'a compenser artificiellement dans le
texte en augmentant le tabac ça veut
dire que si on votait cette proposition
de loi il faudrait passer le tarif d'un
paquet de cigarettes je crois à 25 ou 30
euros madame la Présidente Chatelain on
ne défend pas les institutions à coups
de propositions de loi
anticonstitutionnel ce gouvernement
toute façon finir a par tomber on peut
pas continuer si vous voulez à gouverner
un pays avec une minorité de députés et
dans le pays une très faible pourcentage
de soutien quand je vois monsieur de
Courson qui a été l'apôtre d'une rigueur
budgétaire totale qui lui-même a porté
des amendements pour la retraite à 65
ans devenir le Che Guevara de Monsieur
Mélenchon je regarde ça avec un peu
d'ironie va renforcer les sanctions
notre phrase du jour est signée Gabriel
Attal le ministre des comptes publics a
présenté un vaste plan contre la fraude
sociale évaluation qui estime autour de
2 milliards 800 millions d'euros par an
la fraude aux allocations sociales c'est
l'équivalent du budget du ministère des
Affaires étrangères ministre des comptes
publics proposent de fusionner la carte
d'identité avec la carte Vitale vous
avez des personnes ça peut arriver qui
viennent en France pour se faire soigner
et qui utilise une carte Vitale on leur
prête ou qu'on leur loue bref une carte
vitale qui n'est pas la leur aujourd'hui
il y a plus de 30% des cartes vitales
sur laquelle il y a pas de photo par
exemple puisque c'est des cartes vitales
anciennes qui ont été gardées il y a pas
de date de péremption ça représente des
sommes importantes évidemment c'est à
chaque fois une part de milliers de
milliards d'euros c'est à chaque fois
une forme de trahison et à la petite
fraude et il y a la grosse fraude la
fraude fiscale c'est quand même la
grosse fraude et c'est d'abord à celle
là qu'il faut s'attaquer c'est
aujourd'hui qui est inauguré la première
grande usine française de batterie de
voitures électriques à Billy Berclau
dans Pas de Calais avec à la clé la
création de plusieurs milliers d'emplois
ce sont
[Musique]
quatre pour la région
n'utilisez pas des grands trucs que l'on
vous dit parce que comme vous n'êtes pas
je vous propose d'écouter maintenant le
professeur molima qui est chef de
service de pharmacologie médicale au
circuit de Bordeaux qui est non mais
c'est lui écouter ce type d'insulter
je l'écoute non je ne l'écoute pas je
raccroche vous faites ça c'est pas
compliqué ces articles pro LGBTQ plus
sont vendus par les supermarchés target
lors du mois des fiertés des vêtements
organisé depuis 10 ans mais cette année
ça ne passe pas appel au boycott
incident dans les magasins et même Raph
antit target je ne lis pas vos bêtises
je n'écoute pas votre télé je ne lis pas
les journaux qui médisent de moi je le
fais pas voilà est-ce qu'on peut est-ce
qu'on peut avancer l'opinion résultat
target a retirer certains des produits
provoquant la colère d'autres clients